[Music]
now the movie it looks gorgeous it's in
black and white is it different acting
in black and white black and white
acting is a real challenge and it's
actually kind of dangerous I threw my
back out okay because uh what I'm bad it
sounds absurd well no no it's not it was
it more dangerous special skill and it's
a lot of work to get into black and
white I could I could it's just we you
know what it raises the stakes you know
and and a little bit of your true self
comes out you guys want me to show you
see some black and white this is black
and white act this is black and white
Aggie takes me a moment to get into it
so here goes
[Music]
oh that's amazing it's amazing how do
you how do you feel I feel like the
stakes are higher I feel like my true
self is really coming out I'm still
funny but I'm a little bit dramatical
you should try it Conan I can't do you
want to see him do it watch this I've
never done this to me let me try it okay
you got a push you got to push the color
out push it out there you go buddy
they're amazing
it is the world it's the world is like
you said the stakes are much higher yes
in this environment is that there's an
air of of danger and Menace around me
yeah it really is
anything could happen I wonder how and
Easter you were to check in on Annie
[Applause]
I'm not the one you should be worried
about
I want 30,000 cash you'll never see that
golden monkey statue again see this is
the problem with black and white it
turns people into evil [ __ ] I see
yeah and clearly up there mustache don't
they have but they have mirrors in black
and white land my characters is twisted
is my face yeah so uh Bob how do we get
back to color usually need a good eight
hours of sleep uh or you could just cut
to let's go to commercial we've got a
commercial day